The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: Good evening people.
I place so much emphasis on
Renoir's camera because I
think it's so
fundamentally expresses
his sense of experience.
And if you become attentive
to the really quiet and subtle
ways in which Renoir's camera
is almost always in action,
is a part of the
story in some sense,
you can begin to capture
something of his importance
in the history of cinema.
Because no director or
apprentice director, whoever
studied, looked
at Renoir's films
came away from it the
same, and his influence
is almost impossible
to fully measure.
there are no
cinematic traditions,
after Renoir, that haven't,
at least in some degree,
even if not directly, then
indirectly through other people
who've been influenced
by him have been
shaped by Renoir's example.
And I wanted to
give you one more
instance of Renoir's camera.
This is from a film I've
mentioned, but not shown you.
It's from the last of
his great French films.
Some people, many
people would say it's
his greatest film, one
of the great masterpieces
in the history of movies,
the rules of the game.
The only reason I don't
show it in our course
is that it's, in many
ways, a more difficult,
a more complex film
then Grand Illusion.
there's a grand clarity, or
simplicity of a certain kind.
not a simplicity of character,
or a vision, or a theme,
but a simplicity of
intention that becomes clear,
at least after the
fact in Grand Illusion.
It's a more accessible film,
especially for Americans,
I think.
The Rules of The Game,
much more profoundly,
is a meditation
on the theme that
is also present
in Grand Illusion,
as you'll see this evening, the
theme of historical transition.
But it's a much more complex
and extended meditation
on what was happening
to French society
in this immense
transition that took place
at the beginning of
the 20th century.
Essentially, it's a
transition, as you'll
see dramatized in the film
we're showing tonight,
Grand Illusion,
It's a transition
from an aristocratic to
a middle class culture.
From an aristocratic
dispensation,
to a quasi democratic, or
more democratic dispensation.
And this was a topic
which preoccupied
many directors, Renoir
especially, and is
a kind of central topic in both
Rules of the Game and Grand
Illusion.
This scene from
Rules of the Game
is maybe his least
subtle in some ways.
Or rather, the
subtlety is harder
to see if you're just
looking at a clip.
The subtlety is involved in
the characters themselves,
who have already,
in some degree,
been established in a kind
of individuality, which
then further expresses itself in
the scene you're going to see.
The basic situation of
the Rules of the Game
is a classically powerful one.
it's essentially a
weekend of festivities.
A marquee, a grand
figure, presumably who
owns a remarkable chateau,
invites some friends
for a weekend of games
and shooting, hunting,
at his great chateau
in the country.
And the film is a kind
of series of tableau,
or a series of
festivities, all of which
are cankered, or
damaged in some way.
It's as if we have a sense
that each of the festivities
or festivals that are dramatized
in the Rules of the Game
are diminished versions of
something that, in the past,
had great authority, power,
and cultural centrality,
but have become now diminished,
and even parodically reduced
versions of what they
had been when they were
part of a coherent culture.
it's almost as if these
festivals and rituals have
become-- are recognized by the
film, although not necessarily
by the characters
inside the film,
as vestiges of a time
that has now passed.
And the most dramatic
instance of this subject,
or the embodiment
of this theme, is
the scene you're going to see.
It's the hunting scene.
And I want you to, sort of,
at least get a sense of it,
not only because it's
an important film
and I'd like to fix
it in your mind.
Maybe give you a taste
of it so you'll go out
and look at the film yourself.
these two films, Grand
Illusion and Rules
of the Game are certainly
the pinnacle of Renoir's art,
and people who know
these films deeply
know something
important about film,
know something important
about what works of art are.
So I want to see
for that reason.
But I also want
you to see to get
one more experience,
outside of Grand Illusion,
of the way Renoir's
camera behaves.
especially the way it
establishes a relationship
between character and
ground, between character
and environment.
And here, of course,
the camera's job
is not only to tell us
something about the relations
among the characters,
and to show
us their interactions in as
economically powerful a way as
possible, but also
to give us a sense
of this grand ritual gone bad.
OK.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[HORN BLOWS]
-[INAUDIBLE]
[END PLAYBACK]
PROFESSOR: Freeze it one second.
That little character
who's giving instructions,
you will recognize him.
The actor's name
is Dalio, and he's
the one who plays Rosenthal
in Grand Illusion.
In this film, he
plays the marquis.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-[SPEAKING FRENCH]
PROFESSOR: You see how powerful
it is not to have fake music?
What, just the effect
of that is on the film?
I shouldn't say fake
music, non-diegetic music,
music that's not part
of the scene itself.
There's Dalio.
-[SPEAKING FRENCH]
[HORN BLOWING]
[CLATTERING]
[END PLAYBACK]
PROFESSOR: Freeze it
for a second, please.
I wish we had time
to dwell on this,
and I won't do this too
much because I'll run out
of time for what I
need to tell you,
but tell me what you
see here quickly.
Make some conclusions about--
what about this great ritual?
Immediately, what would we
think if we're watching this?
What's one conclusion
you draw from this?
Is this hunting the
activity of brave
pioneering souls
who are confronting
the dangers of the wilderness?
[LAUGHS]
Right?
It's an unbelievably
controlled, and in many ways,
murderous environment isn't it?
What have we begun to feel
about these creatures that
are being flushed out?
Tremendous sympathy
for them, right?
We're hostile to
the adults, right?
We're hostile to the
human beings in the scene.
We think there's something
the matter with this.
And of course in the
olden days, presumably
in the days when
such hunts occurred
in a more coherent,
and less forced way,
you need beaters to go
around in other words,
making noise to scare the
few vestiges of rabbits
and other game out into the
open so people with giant guns
could kill them. right?
in the 16th or the 15th
century, or the 18th century,
these fields were
teeming with game.
Now, in the 20th
century, you have
to beat the sticks to
get them to come out.
What a parody of what
an actual hunt would be.
Go ahead.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[CLATTERING]
PROFESSOR: When this film was
made-- I forgot the number,
I have it in my notes, but
I couldn't find them there,
I left them in my office.
A certain number
of these animals
were actually killed in
the making of the film.
I forgot the number, but
it's a significant number.
[GUNSHOTS]
PROFESSOR: If today,
they made such a film,
there are rules that don't
allow them to kill animals.
[GUNSHOTS]
[BIRD CHIRP]
[HORN BLOWS]
[END PLAYBACK]
PROFESSOR: OK, you get
some sense of how powerful
a satirist, but also how
quiet a satirist, he can be.
It's not as if the
film-- it's not
as if there's someone there
saying, isn't this horrible.
He's leaving it to the
audience to figure out,
although, it doesn't take too
much to figure it out, does it?
What you can pick up from
this, it makes, maybe,
the scene that I've shown you
may make the scene seem cruder
than it is.
Virtually all the characters,
faces that you've seen.
most of them, anyway, are
major characters in the film.
And even by this
time in the film,
you've gotten to know
some of them quite well.
So they've been humanized
and individuated,
and that makes the
brutality, to which they
are mostly oblivious, of what's
happening even more powerful.
You don't hate the characters
who are doing the shooting.
you know them for the comic,
and damaged, and ambitious,
and idealistic, and
foolish characters
they've already shown themselves
to be by the time they
get into this scene.
It's almost as if they,
themselves, are also victims
of this ritual they're part of.
So there's a kind of subtlety
that you can't pick up
on just watching the clip, that
is present for any audience
member.
But I wanted you to see that
this scene, also in part,
again, to show you how
powerfully Renoir's camera is
able to create emotional
and intellectual responses
in the audience, in a way
that is, in some sense,
diametrically opposed
to what we might call
expressionist directors like
Hitchcock or Eisenstein might
do.
By manipulating our
attitudes, by constant,
by very rapid editing, and by
giving us high or low angle
shots that control our emotional
response because of the way
we're seeing things.
Renoir's strategies
can be just as powerful
in terms of emotional
and moral reaction,
but Renoir's strategy
is quite different.
Present the evidence, in
some sense, to the audience.
Keep the camera at a level
that allows the full action
to be taken in.
I hope you realize
that there were
relatively few
cuts in that scene,
and in most of Renoir's
work the number of edits
is relatively small compared
to the number of scenes
that are extended, the amount
of long takes that we have.
And there are certain
moments in the film where
he will vary this strategy.
For example, and you
might want to watch
for this in tonight's
film, there's
one moment in tonight's film,
an interview between two
of the central characters, the
German prison warden played
by Erik Von Stroheim,
and the French aristocrat
named du Boeldieu, played by
an actor named de Fresnay.
And in this scene between
the German and the Frenchman,
one of the things
we recognize is,
because they belong to
the aristocratic class,
they have a lot in common.
They speak English, for example,
because they both know English,
even though one's a German
and one's a Frenchman.
And there is a sense in the
film, a very powerful one
that's established, that they
have, in some sense, a greater
connection to each other than
they have with other soldiers
in their own armies.
And the film meditates
on these distinctions,
and especially on this
conundrum of social class,
in rather a complex
way as I'll suggest.
Well, in the very first
scene between Boeldieu
and Rauffenstein, the
German and the Frenchman,
Renoir uses a fairly standard
procedure, much more common
to other directors, it's
sometimes called a shot,
counter shot style.
it's especially common
on American television,
but it's common in the
movies too, in which, when
you see characters
in conversation,
you'll get relatively
rapid cutting.
And you look at one face,
then the camera will shift,
and you look back
at the other face.
They'll be a cut, and
you'll look-- right?
And you'll constantly
shift back and forth,
this shot, counter shot style.
But he, Renoir uses this
kind of style rarely,
because first of all, it
involves the idea of cutting.
It involves the
idea of separation.
Why use shot/ counter
shot, Renoir would say,
when I can move my camera
like this and show the two
characters together?
And move it around
in another way,
and show the back of one
character's head, and the way
the other is reacting.
In other words, if
the camera's part
of the action, a fluid
part of the action,
I can show you more about
character, Renoir would say.
But in that particular
scene, he doesn't do it
in this first
extended interview.
It lasts about two
minutes and 45 seconds,
and it uses 21 shots.
21 separate shots in two
minutes and 45 seconds.
For Renoir that's a
tremendous number of edits.
and it why would he do it there?
Because it's very unusual
for him to use this shot,
counter shot style in the film.
Why would he do it?
He wants to emphasize
their separation,
their isolation from each other,
their distance from each other.
And there is a later
see in the film,
near the very end of the
film, again between Boeldieu
and another character.
But this one between the
Boeldieu and Marechal,
the French working class figure
who's on the French side,
just before there's
an attempted escape.
And that scene is almost
as long, two minutes
and 20 seconds long,
but that scene only
has three separate edits in it.
And you might compare it.
The farewell scene is
a very obvious one,
and you'll recognize
it when you see it.
and, of course, the
reason is that he
wants to emphasize,
insofar as it's possible,
that they are together.
He wants to minimize the sense
of isolation in that sequence.
Again, I mention
this because I want
you to become as
attentive as possible,
without destroying your
enjoyment of the film,
to the camera's way of behaving.
to summarize what
I'm trying to say
about the way the
camera works in Renoir,
I want to remind you that,
even in his darkest films,
his camera work carries an
undercurrent of excitement,
even sometimes a kind of joy
at the sheer particularness,
the particularity of the world.
you can sense his awareness of
human ambiguity and his wonder
at the texture of
the visible world
all through his films of
his so-called French period.
And especially in
the film you're
going to see tonight, which is
in many ways in environments
that are very unpoetic right?
The entire film takes place
in a series of prison camps.
The entire film is about
these French prisoners of war.
There is an
introduction or prologue
before they're
captured, and then
after they're
captured we see them
in a series of prison camps.
it's quite an amazing
experience, in some ways,
to watch Renoir's
camera discover
the complexity of a world
that seems, on the surface,
to be so unpromising,
and so uninteresting,
so lacking in texture.
we can think of Renoir's camera
as shy, timid in a sense.
Capable of embarrassment, even.
There's one moment in the
Rules of the Game which partly
involves a force
dimension, so that when
all the guests in the
great estate or castle
go to sleep at night.
They sort of come
out of their rooms,
and start changing bed
partners and things like that.
they have various liaisons.
And there's a moment when the
camera is in this long hallway,
and one of the lovers comes
out to meet another lover,
and it looks as if
the camera actually
backs away in embarrassment,
and looks away as if it says,
oh, that's inappropriate
for me to be looking at.
The camera is humanized in
a very subtle, quiet way all
the way through Renoir's work.
So we think of his camera
as shy, as embarrassed,
reluctant to overhear,
or to intrude.
There are even
moments when it is
distracted, or drawn toward an
apparently irrelevant element.
Times when the camera
hesitates, or even
appears to change its mind.
An uncertain camera,
then, always adjusting
to a world that is, itself,
always shifting and changing.
And of course, that's
the deepest argument
for why the camera
is so restless.
remember, it's not obtrusive.
it's not like to feel the camera
swinging wildly, not at all.
You have to pay attention,
sometimes you won't even
be aware of the
fact of how quietly
and simply the camera-- but
it's as if the camera is always
making adjustments.
As if it's always alive to the
changing character of what it's
looking at, and that very
aliveness reminds you
of how complex reality
is, because reality
itself is always
shifting and changing.
This describes, I
think, something of what
is meant by Renoir's realism.
But there's a kind of lyric
element, as I've mentioned,
even a kind of tranquility,
or pleasure, or joy.
Celebratory impulse in his
camera's gaze that qualifies,
or sweeteners, his realism
of space and character,
and we need to be
aware of that too.
One way to crystallize
this is to suggest
that once we become
attuned to the camera's
forms of attention--
that's a good phrase,
the camera's forms of attention.
There's a wonderful
book about poetry
called forms of attention.
Lyric poetry is what constitutes
a special kind of attention.
We can say that Renoir's
camera is engaged constantly
in these forms of attention.
Once we become aware of that, of
the camera's interest in that,
we become aware of a quiet
continuous struggle, a loving
contest almost, between the
multiple points of interest
in the scene, and the camera's
reluctant gently hesitant
choices.
The menu of things
to see and hear,
Renoir's films keep
telling us, is too rich
to be fully captured,
even by the most eye.
And that's what
I mean when I say
that visual style
can be understood
as a form of moral style.
I want to say a few more words
about Grand Illusion, itself,
to help frame your
experience of it.
It's not a complex film, but
it's a deep and beautiful one,
and I think you'll all
find it very memorable.
First a word about the actors.
or maybe I should
say one other word
about Renoir himself, because
it bears on his actors.
As I implied, or I think,
suggested this afternoon,
one of the most distinctive
features of Renoir's practice--
if you think about the
way is camera behaves,
you can see how logically
connected these elements are--
was that he was an
improvisational director.
He collaborated with his
actors, with this performers.
He didn't come in with an
absolutely fixed script.
he's like the anti-Hitchcock.
Hitchcock has solved
all his problems
before he's come in
to do is shooting,
Renoir has just begun the
process of making his movie.
he has an idea of
the subject matter,
He knows what he's doing.
I don't mean that he's
working completely blind,
but he allows
discovery to take place
in the course of the
making of his movies,
and he's very deeply
involved in collaborating
with this performers.
So that, for example,
when he had already
begun working on
the movie-- I don't
think they'd begun shooting it
yet-- but they were very far
along in creating the movie,
and in casting the movie,
when they discovered that
Erich Von Strohein, who
was that already by the
time this film was made,
a very well known
actor and director.
Much, in fact, incredibly
admired director
--both an actor and a director,
agreed to join the film.
And when he agreed
to join the film,
he and Renoir began
to collaborate
on expanding the role
that Von Strohein plays.
And you'll understand what an
immensely helpful contribution
to, what could we call it,
to the ecology of the movie,
to the sense of the
movie Von Strohein made,
because he's one of the
dominant characters.
if we try to imagine Grand
Illusion with a much reduced
role for the Von
Strohein character,
it's a much lesser film.
So you can recognize what an
extraordinary contribution Von
Strohein made.
Now, he not only
made contributions
to questions about the dialogue,
what the character would say,
expanded the role, but even
made suggestions about how
the character would look.
How the character
would be costumed.
I think it was Von Strohein
who emphasized, even more fully
than Renoir had
originally intended,
that the Von Strohein
character is a war casualty.
That he has ram
rod up is back, he
has to wear gloves because
his hands are horribly burned.
He's a cripple, and that's why
he's now running prison camps.
Because he's not useful
for anything else, right?
And there's the sense that he's
a damaged, wounded figure even
from the very beginning of the
film, when we first meet him.
So that's important
in itself, but there's
a second thing
about Von Strohein
that I want to emphasize to you.
it shows you how
subtly Renoir was
aware of how he
could utilize all
the elements available
to him as a filmmaker.
Von Strohein was especially
well known as an actor,
for roles in which
he would play--
this was a special true in
roles he played in the United
States-- in which he would play
a dangerous, scary martinet.
There were even hints of
sadomasochism about the role
sometimes.
So he would play brutal
prison camp wardens, right?
brutal police types, militarist
types, violent husbands.
And, in fact, he was
understood, also, as a villain.
He often played roles that
were recognizably evil roles.
He came to be known as
the man you love to hate.
That was like a sort of motto
that was attached to his name.
And, when you want
your Grand Illusion,
one of the things I
hope you'll think about
is the complex way in which
that inherited idea of the Von
Strohein character is
complicated, undermined,
and humanized.
Because, in many ways, he still
is the villain in the piece,
but he's a humanized villain.
he becomes a complex character,
as much a victim of history
as any of the other
characters in the film.
So there's a sense in which,
what Renoir and Von Strohein,
together, are doing is
taking the persona that Von
Strohein had established, and
undercutting it, undermining it
in some slight way, creating
a much greater resonance
for the character, exactly
because of the ways in which he
first that appears to fulfill
the expectations that he's
an evil villain, and
then as the film goes on,
this sense is
undermined, complicated,
and you realize he's a
human being with powers
of generosity, although
also certain limitations.
he's a German, he's
prejudiced, he doesn't really
like the French,
especially doesn't
like working class people, most
especially doesn't like Jews.
he's an imperfect
character, but you
see this he's deeply humanized.
And something of the
same kind of thing
happens in the film's treatment
of the Jean Gabin character.
He's the character who plays
Marechal, the actor who
plays Marechal, the working
class Frenchman who,
along with de Boeldieu and
the Jew played by Dalio,
a character called Rosenthal.
These three are the
central French characters,
and we see them moving from
prison camp to prison camp
through the film.
that group is the central
group of the film.
We follow them as
the film goes on.
The Gabin character too, was,
in many ways, the most famous
actor, if not in Europe,
certainly and France
of the late '20s and '30s.
major, major figure.
and he was especially associated
with working class roles.
,
And, most especially
associated with roles--
he was like an early
Jack Nicholson.
An even more powerful version
of it, because he became famous
for these moments
in the films when
he would go nuts, when he would
have a fit, when he would start
screaming, or he would lose it.
He would rant or rave.
In some films he was in he would
have a climactic scene-- this
may be, in fact, where
the stereotype began-- he
would have a climactic scene.
Often he would be a suicidal
proletarian, a suicidal worker
up against the
forces of capitalism,
or the forces of the police.
The Gabin character
had frequent roles
like this, in which
he would essentially
lose all rational control,
and rant, and rave,
and scream, sometimes die.
he was so famous
for this, and this
was such a fundamental
part of his persona,
that he had written into
most of his contracts
that he had to have a
scene which he did this.
He had to have at
least one scene
in the film in which
he sort of went
Cucamonga, in which he lost it.
Now, one of the most subtle
things about this film
is, there is such a
moment in this film.
Watch for it, because
it's so quiet compared
to what you might expect,
that you might miss it.
But it's really there.
And in fact, the way in which
it both fulfills, but also
undermines, our expectations
about this character,
again, tells us
something about the way
in which Renoir and his
collaborating actors
were able to create
immensely nuanced meanings,
possibilities, out
on the raw material,
not only of the
story of the film,
and of the setting
of the film, but even
the past history
of the performers.
I want to say just
a couple of things
about some of the
dominant themes
in the film to help organize
your experience of it.
And I'm borrowing
here, or deeply
influenced here, by
two critics especially,
or perhaps I should
say parenthetically.
You should probably assume
that almost anything I say
has been said by someone else
at some time in the past.
the job of a teacher,
as I conceive it,
is not to come up with totally
original arguments every time,
because no one
can be so original
as to say everything
that's wonderful
about particular texts, or
about a whole phenomenon
like the movies.
So a good teacher draws on that.
When I really am drawing
on a prior scholar, who
I know has shaped the
arguments I'm making,
or has given me the
categories I'm using,
I mention them by name.
But, of course, I've
been teaching for so long
that much of this must not
be unconsciously absorbed
into my psyche, and I
don't always know this,
so I'm not saying that
those moments where
I haven't made this
acknowledgement
are free of such influence.
Quite the opposite.
But I do want to mention two
scholars who have especially
influenced me on Renoir, because
virtually all the things I've
told you about Renoir, though
I've made the ideas my own,
come from these.
One is a Frenchman named
Alexander Sesonske.
And he wrote a wonderful book,
I think a several volume book,
on Renoir that taught me a
tremendous amount, especially
about his French period.
And the other is the,
now California scholar,
Leo Braudy, one of
whose essays I've asked
you to read in this course.
He's written a wonderful
book on Renoir.
And, although I
have read the book,
I learned more about Renoir
from Braudy in conversation,
because he was my colleague many
years ago when we were teaching
together in the English
department at Yale,
and he's one of the
people who turned me
into a person interested and
movies, interested in film.
So, Leo Braudy, B-R-A-U-D-Y,
Alexander Sesonske,
S-E-S-O-N-S-K-E, the two
principal scholars and critics
behind what I've been saying,
both this afternoon and this
evening.
Dominant themes.
One.
The prison camp as a microcosm.
There's a wonderful
passage, at one point
in the movie, where one of
the character's said "everyone
would die of the
disease of his class,
if the war did not
reconcile all microbes".
think about the
implications of that.
the idea is that one of the
things that makes this prison
camp such a fascinating place
is that it is, in some sense,
a microcosm of the larger world.
and especially if you
think of the prison camp
beyond just the grouping
of the French soldiers,
the French prisoners
who we follow primarily,
what you can recognize if you
back away, because we are told
about, or we meet, and
we see briefly some
of the other prisoners.
There are Russian prisoners
and there's other kinds
of prisoners as well.
There's a sense that the prison
camp is a kind of microcosm,
at least of Europe, if not
of the world as a whole.
And, more specifically, the
way in which the prison camp
is a microcosm for
the social striations
that organize outer society.
There's a working class, there
seems to be a middle class,
you'll notice that
there's a scholar who
has a copy of Pindar, the great
ancient poet, who treasures
his work on Pindar-- he's one
of my favorite minor characters
in the film because
of his commitment
to literature despite the
war, and despite the miseries
of prison camp.
And what you can see
is, in a certain sense,
that Renoir is delighted by the
idea that a kind of microcosm
is created.
And if you watch the variations
amongst the Frenchmen,
and again, if you think about
that fragment of a scene I
showed you this afternoon,
of these characters at dinner
table in the in the
prison camp, you'll
begin to see more fully how
powerfully and interestingly,
complexly, he differentiates
his characters from each other.
Now That fragment
that you saw, I
hope you realized one of
the characters was an actor.
It becomes clearer if you
watch the whole scene,
but he's a very histrionic
and theatrical character,
he bursts into song
all the time, right?
And then there's
the aristocrat who's
looking down his monocle
very, very austerely
and his lip seems curled
in a permanent gesture
of condescension.
And so forth.
Watch how richly, how
complexly, the characters are
distinguished from each
other by social class,
by profession, and so forth.
I don't want to romanticize
or idealize this argument,
because I'm not
suggesting that when
he says it's a
microcosm of the world,
he wants to celebrate
that microcosm,
although he's interested in it.
Renoir is also aware
of the limitations.
it's not as if he's
suggesting that this
is a perfect community at all.
One reason is, they're
forced together,
but they're being
forced together
makes them share,
forces them to come out
of their limitations
in certain ways,
to overcome certain
of their prejudices,
although night never fully.
But what it also
does is reveal them.
And we can and we can
see how both processes--
the process of adjusting to
people different from yourself,
and maybe overcoming
some of your class
or racial prejudices-- is
a part of the experience
that the characters
in the film have,
but another part
of the experience
is that they come up against the
differences between them, some
of which can never be breached.
Let me mention one scene which
dramatizes this ambiguity very
deeply.
There's one moment in the film,
very powerful moment I think,
in which the character
played by Gabin,
the Marechal
character is wounded
in a early part of the film.
in fact, in the dinner
scene that I showed you
this afternoon, you'll see
that, at a certain point,
his comrade sitting at the
table cuts his meat for him
because his hand is injured.
And, I don't know if it's in
this scene or subsequent scene,
there's a moment when
another character in the film
washes Marechal's feet.
Why is foot washing
instantly a symbolic thing?
Who knows the answer?
AUDIENCE: Cause, like,
Mary washed Jesus' feet.
PROFESSOR: All right.
There's a scene in the Bible,
in the 12th chapter of John,
in which Mary or Martha,
I can't remember which,
washes Christ's feet.
And then, in the
very next chapter,
at The Last Supper
Christ, himself,
washes the feet
of his disciples.
And in fact, the washing
of feet is, in Catholic
and in certain other
Christian rituals,
an actual official ritual.
It used to be much more
common than it is today,
but it's still done in
certain Catholic countries
at the advent of Holy Week.
so it's a deeply symbolic act
in which Christ, himself, is
washing the feet
of his disciples,
and the message he
gives is everyone,
you should now do
this to your Fellows.
The implication being no one
is better than anyone else.
a radically democratic invasion,
in some sense, of God's love.
And where has this practice been
recently, very dramatically,
and publicly revived?
Who's been doing it?
The Pope, the new pope.
Haven't you read about this?
The new pope has been
doing this, washing
the feet of parishioners,
a symbolic gesture in which
God's emissary on
earth is behaving
with the humility that
Jesus Christ, himself would.
So the foot washing scene in our
film has this sort of resonance
to it, even though there's no
openly religious reference.
but it has a similar
kind of significance.
And they are carrying on
a kind of conversation
as the feet are being washed.
And what you feel is,
boy, what a moving scene.
the man who's doing
the washing doesn't
feel that he's being
condescended to,
or that he's being diminished
in any way by doing it.
The man whose feet
are being washed
is not embarrassed
to have it happen.
What a scene of
solidarity and community.
And you could wax
very poetic about what
a scene of community, and
yet, watch how the scene ends.
There's a moment at which,
as he's drying his feet,
Marechal asks the foot washer,
what do you do for a living?
at some point during
their conversation
he says I am a cadastre.
What that means is something
like city planning.
He's a city planner.
And so the Marechal character
hears this and they go on,
at the very end of
the scene, Marechal
turns to his foot
washer and he says,
what does that mean, cadastre?
The implication being
that they're vocabularies
aren't even the same.
what it dramatizes is the
distance between them.
He's been sitting there having
this conversation with him,
but he didn't even
say, gee I have
no idea what that word
means, I certainly
have no idea what
you do for a living.
It's a way of reminding us,
yes they've come together,
yes they're sharing
space, yes they're
doing something that
dramatizes human solidarity,
and yet also how
separated they are.
Again and again in
the film we have
this sort of double experience,
in which we see characters
make contact with each other, or
even sacrifice for each other,
and at the same time we're
aware of their differences.
Watch for this.
It's very powerful and moving.
It's a form of moral realism,
in which the film refuses
to simplify what it wants to
say about human experience.
Very powerful example of
this in the relationship
between the Jew, Rosenthal,
who's proud of his wealth,
he's the heir of a
department store fortune.
but because he's a Jew, and
because he's nouveau rich,
he can never be part
of the aristocracy,
his relation to the Marechal
character's very complex.
Marechal, as I mentioned
this afternoon,
retains a kind of French
working class characteristic
antisemitism.
And there are moments
when you can feel
the hostility between them.
When the two of them finally
try to make an escape
from the prison, and
they actually are away
from one of the
prisons for a while,
and you see the Rosenthal
character hurts his foot.
And there's a moment in
which it looks like, gee,
if the Marechal
character stays with him,
he's putting himself
in danger as well.
And they get into a fight.
And Rosenthal says, go
away, leave me alone!
And Marechal says,
all right I will!
it's a very wonderful
scene, because they
start singing at each other.
it's a form of
singing hostility.
So there's a comic
dimension to it.
it's really rich.
But what is also
being dramatized
there are the limitations
of the characters.
Marechal's antisemitism
rises, comes to the surface.
Their hostility
toward each other
comes to the surface
at that moment,
although of course,
they also overcome it.
And there are many other
such moments in the film.
The relationship
between de Boeldieu
and his German counterpart,
the aristocratic German,
is also a version of
this kind of thing.
as I've already implied,
a second central theme
of the film has to
do with what we might
call barriers and boundaries.
There's the barrier
of social class,
which I've mentioned already.
There's the barrier of
language and culture, right?
The Germans and the
French are at war.
The Russians don't speak the
same language as the Germans,
the English don't speak the
same language as the French.
again and again what separates
people is dramatized for us,
although there's also a
longing the film to transcend
these boundaries, they
can't always be transcended.
Sometimes these
boundaries are shown
to be foolish and trivial,
or at best, unhelpful.
there are many examples in
the film, both of language
and of geography, as
well as of social class,
but let me mention
just two of them,
There's one wonderful
moment in the film.
The French prisoners have been
digging a tunnel, an escape
tunnel.
And they've almost
completed the tunnel
when the Germans come
and say, all right we're
moving you out of your
barracks and we're putting
these English prisoners in.
and so the French are
very unhappy about this,
because they've almost
completed their tunnel.
So, at great danger to
himself, the Marechal character
breaks ranks, does
a kind of trick
where he drops a
suitcase, I think,
and he bends over to try to pick
it up to give them an excuse
to talk to the English prisoners
who are going to change places
with him.
He wants to tell me
English prisoners,
there's a m you could escape.
But it turns out he's not
able to give them the message,
because the English
don't understand French
and he can't speak English.
So the English Prisoners
end up going into the--
without ever
knowing that there's
a tunnel waiting for them that's
almost ready to be completed.
An example of the
barrier, the way language
separates people,
that in many ways
can be said to be frustrating.
One more example.
At the very end of
the film, there's
a moment when the two
characters, Marechal
and Rosenthal are making their
escape across a great field,
a great white field of snow.
And they're running across the
field, and the camera backs up,
and we see them being
watched by German soldiers.
One of the soldiers
picks up his rifle,
he says they're
making an escape,
and starts to aim at them.
Then, all of a sudden, he stops.
watch for that how it happens.
I think his partner says,
wait a minute, hold off.
Why doesn't he shoot?
And then we see Marechal
and Rosenthal disappear
across an invisible boundary,
and the German says, well
they've crossed the border.
They're no longer in
Germany, I can't shoot them,
they're now in Belgium.
But the fact is there's no
boundary there, it's all snow.
It's a snowy field.
How arbitrary that boundary is.
But again and again the
film we have this theme
of barriers and boundaries.
What separates us?
And also, one last thing about
the question of social class.
Maybe the most
disturbing and powerful
insight that the film has
about social class, one
that Americans tend to resist.
But I encourage you
not to resist it.
Those of you not from
the United States
will, perhaps, understand
this more easily,
although Americans
need to understand it,
is the extent to which
one's social class
shapes one's identity.
That is to say, one of the
things we feel in this film
is that de Boeldieu's nature
is a function of his having
been raised as an aristocrat.
There are wonderful
scenes between de Boeldieu
and Marechal, where
Marechal says to him,
there's a wall between us.
And you're so undemonstrative.
Marechal doesn't trust
him because he belongs
to a different class,
even though, of course,
they're Frenchmen after all.
And in the end, nationality
trumps class in this film,
as you'll see.
But in this sort of distinction
or difference between Marechal
and de Boeldieu, we have another
expression of this sense,
of this idea, of this
recognition that one's
personality, itself, what
one likes and dislikes,
ones fundamental
nature is in part
shaped by the class
into which one is born.
We're not born utterly free.
We don't have absolute
choice in what we become.
Our characters are
shaped, controlled,
by the circumstances
in which we live,
and the film profoundly
understands that.
It understands our desire
to breach those limitations,
to go beyond them, and
it celebrates our impulse
to do so.
But it also
recognizes the degree
to which we remain confined
within personalities that
are partly controlled
or shaped by forces far
beyond our individual control,
and that are especially
located in the social
class to which we belong.
Finally, as I mentioned
this afternoon,
the theme of
historical transition
is at the heart of
this remarkable film.
And you'll understand very
clearly what is going on there.
Again, dramatized
even more complexly
and fully in Rules of the Game,
it's a central topic here.
aristocratic traditions
are giving way
to modernity in this film.
And we're aware of them
in all kinds of ways.
Even in the nostalgic
way in which
de Boeldieu and Rauffenstein
carry on their conversations.
they have experiences in
common because they belong
to the aristocracy, a class
that transcended, in some sense,
at least in part,
transcended national origins.
That aristocratic
dispensation is disappearing.
In fact, this first World War
completely obliterated it,
and Renoir's not the
only one who said this.
apart from
scholarship, there are
a number of wonderful
novels, for example,
that deal with
the transformation
of European society because
of the First World War,
and Renoir's film
is one such text.
Renoir's maturity.
This is another way of
talking about the complexity,
or the richness of his films.
I simply want to
remind you, at the end,
that one way to think
about what Renoir is doing
is to recognize that
his visual style is,
in some sense, an embodiment of
the ambition not to simplify.
To be as fluid and as
attentive to the world
as it's possible to be.
And one could say
that that visual,
that commitment to the way the
camera acts toward the world,
is a version of a larger kind
of maturity or complexity
that's revealed in the
content of his work, as well.
Take the characters.
I've already mentioned
the key point here.
The way in which
the characters are
both flawed, full of
weaknesses, but also
attractive in certain ways.
The way in which a
Rosenthal is marred
by his pride in his
family's wealth.
The way in which
the Gabin character
is marred by his antisemitism
and his lack of education.
The way in which the
de Boeldieu character
is damaged, or limited,
by his aristocratic
reserve, and his impulse
toward a kind of condescending
superiority, which you
could see articulated
in the very first
moment you see him,
at the very beginning
of the film, where
he's tsk tsking about the
incompetence of his own troops.
So there's a
complexity of character
that reflects the maturity
of the film's vision of life,
and there's a complexity in
the story, because think of it
for a minute.
This is a war story, but it's
a war story without battles.
Some people have said
it's the happiest war
story they ever saw.
One way of organizing
the film is
to see it as a series of
meals, in which character
sit down at table and
share convivial thoughts.
It's not a sufficient
way of thinking about it,
but it's a partial way
of thinking about it.
so, although it's
as film about war,
about the consequences of
war, it doesn't show shooting.
And in fact, although
it's a war story,
it's about most deeply, human
community and human solidarity,
and about historical transition.
Well, one way to crystallize
all of this, or to summarize it,
is to remind you of the
complexity of the title-- Grand
Illusion.
the title seems to
me to have at least
four separate implications,
or four separate ways
of understanding.
It's a measure of what
I've called multiplicity,
or complexity.
what would the title mean?
What is the grand illusion
to which the title refers?
Well, one is surely this.
Remember, the film was made
on the eve of World War II
even though it is ostensibly
set in World War I.
And, in fact, it was
recognized as an anti-war film.
It was banned in
Germany and in Italy.
President Roosevelt
in the United States
said anyone who loves
freedom should see this film.
I think he was right.
The Title.
One of the things about that
war, that first World War, some
of you will know, was it
was identified especially
by the American President
Woodrow Wilson as the war
to end wars.
So one deep grand,
but horrible, illusion
is that this is the
war to end wars.
That there won't be anymore
wars after this one.
A second possible meaning
of the title is this.
one of the central events in the
film, I haven't mentioned yet,
and it's, maybe, the most
memorable interlude in the film
is, after Marechal and
Rosenthal make their escape
from one of the prison
camps, they're on the run.
They're in Germany, and
it's the middle of winter.
And they managed to
find safety in the home
of a German woman whose husband
is away at the war, perhaps
dead.
And she is there
trying to manage a farm
with her young daughter Elsa,
and Marechal and Rosenthal
spend the winter with them,
and it's an idle in the winter.
It's very moving.
And, again, the barriers of
language are present there.
At the very end of
their idle in the woods,
we have Marechal say to the
child, --I called her Elsa,
I think it's Lottie.
He looks at the girl and, in
bad German, he says [GERMAN].
He says blue eyes.
But he's very proud
of himself for having
been able to articulate
two German words.
But the fact that he's
done that is a mark
of his having reached out.
And the implication, more
than the implication,
is he becomes the woman's lover.
while they are what
while they spend
the winter in this way--
and the German woman,
at a certain point, when they
first take refuge in her place,
a German soldier searching for
these guys, comes to the door,
comes to the window and
speaks to the window.
And the widow protects them.
So a second grand
illusion may very well
be, look, this is a
very lovely story,
but how believable is it?
French soldiers on the
run from a prison camp
find a farmhouse in which
a German widow takes them
in and protects them
from the German soldiers.
It's a nice story, but
is it a grand illu--
if it is an illusion, maybe it's
a grand one, a wonderful one.
Not just a large one,
but a valuable one.
So that's a second way in which
the title resonates for me.
The third grand
illusion has to do
with the community of the
prisoners, the solidarity
and community that's dramatized
in the film in the end.
The de Boeldieu character
sacrifices himself
for the good of the
other, something
that we might find surprising
at first, given his distance
from the other characters.
and there is a sense all
the way through the film,
that a kind of
community or solidarity
has been established
amongst the men,
especially amongst
the Frenchmen.
And especially that a kind of
friendship between Rosenthal
and Marechal has been forged.
Well, again, maybe
that's a grand illusion.
The idea that you can
transcend social class,
that you can transcend the
ethnic prejudices into which
you were born, and with which
you've been brainwashed.
So that's another kind of
potential grand illusion.
And then finally, the
fourth example I would give.
the fourth nuance
that one could add
to the title, the grand
illusion of movies themselves.
What are movies but
grand illusions, right?
They're two dimensional,
not three dimensional,
but when we watch
them we feel we've
entered into a real world.
The grand illusion
of movies themselves
is part of what the
title alludes to.
Well, something of the
complexity and maturity
of Renoir's vision
of experience,
sense of human character,
and sense of history
is embodied, then,
in the complexity
of the title of his movie.